All right, good afternoon, everyone.
Seeing that the board members are now present,
Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish a quorum?
Member Burr.
Here.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Fatah.
Here.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Navo.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Rucker.
Vice President Strauss.
Here.
Member Son.
You have a quorum.
Okay, I hereby call the March 2021 meeting
of the State Board of Education to order at 2.35 p.m.
And I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Member Fatah, will you please lead us
in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Yes.
Ready, begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation, under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
And congratulations, Member Fatah,
on the college admissions that are rolling in.
We're looking forward to the final decisions next meeting.
Agenda one is our state board priorities item,
and I will launch us with just a few remarks,
welcoming you to our three-day board meeting.
We haven't had one of those for a while.
We have a lot of ground to cover in these coming days,
so I'm gonna keep these remarks quite short.
It is a milestone that we have recently passed,
and we've turned a corner,
and I think we're heading for a light
at the end of the tunnel.
It's been almost exactly one year since we were together
and since normal personal instruction
across the state ceased as educators, parents,
and students pivoted to distance learning
when we discovered COVID-19 in our state.
And now we give a little bit of guitar music.
I'll wait for that to...
That was nice.
And I think on that note, no pun intended,
we'll just note that we are turning the corner,
and we've learned a lot in this last year.
Our public schools, as you know, have been heroic
in getting meals and technology to students and families
and learning how to teach digitally
and finding ways to wrap around
some of our most vulnerable students.
And meanwhile, we have learned how to test for
and treat this disease and how to vaccinate
against its worst effects,
and vaccinations are now taking place
at a rapidly growing rate with priority for our educators.
Thankfully, along with other essential workers
for seniors, we are at a point where we can expect everyone
to be vaccinated by summer,
and we can celebrate the 4th of July with our families
if we've done so.
And we're seeing the momentum build across the state
with more and more schools announcing plans
for the safe return of students, teachers, and staff
to the classrooms that many have so sorely missed.
The governor announced today that 9,000 schools have opened
or have planned reopening dates
in the coming days and weeks,
and these include the largest and smallest districts
that represent students across the spectrum,
including the students who struggle the most.
But beyond just bringing students back,
the governor and the legislature have made a bold commitment
to ensuring that our schools have the resources
to surround students with the social, emotional,
mental health, and academic support that they need
to thrive now and in a post-pandemic world.
SB 86, which the governor signed on March 5th,
provides $6.6 billion, including $2 billion
to provide resources for schools
to provide in-person instruction this spring,
and $4.6 billion for expanded learning opportunities
that will give schools the funding and the flexibility
to add blocks of learning time throughout the school year
and in the summer.
And the expanded learning resources really offer the schools
the freedom to operate outside the constraints
of the traditional agrarian calendar,
hopefully in partnership
with community-based organizations, boys and girls clubs,
YMCAs, camping organizations, and others this summer
to provide an enriching, engaging,
joyful set of learning opportunities
that hopefully will reattach students to school,
to each other and to their teachers,
and that wrap around them with social and emotional
and mental health supports,
as well as effective academic support and tutoring
to accelerate their learning.
We're hopeful that this can launch us on a path
to re-imagining schools so that they focus on the needs
of the child rather than the clock or the calendar.
And this work is really due to the amazing efforts
of so many in our education community.
In our deliberations over the course of this meeting,
we can support this work with support for useful,
informative assessments, additional funding and guidance
for literacy development and support
for a culturally responsive and sustaining curriculum.
So in advance for the good and hard work,
we will do this work this week
and also thank our entire community of educators
and families for their focus and tenacity
throughout this year of regrouping and rethinking
everything about our education system.
And I look forward to the days ahead
as we return to and reinvent our schools.
And with that, we can launch into our agenda.
There is one item on the agenda that has an addendum.
Item two, the Every Student Succeeds Act,
Authorization to Pursue Flexibility
on our Waiver of Assessment,
Accountability and Reporting Requirements.
There is one public hearing on the agenda,
which we will take up tomorrow afternoon.
That is item eight, a petition for the renewal
of a charter school under the oversight
of the local educational agency
designated by the State Board of Education
pursuant to California Education Code Section 47605K2E.
And that is the consideration of the Ross Valley Charter,
which was denied by the Ross Valley
Elementary School District.
The proposed regular consent items are items five and six.
The proposed waiver consent items are W2 through W11.
In terms of changes in the agenda,
we will reopen item one on Thursday afternoon
to take up action on the draft meetings
from our February meeting and receive our liaison reports.
In terms of public input,
members of the public wishing to call in
for public comment should view the live stream
of the meeting to know at what time public comment
will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number,
entering a participant access code,
and then following the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers
when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down
the speaker volume of their computers
if they are following the live webcast
to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute
for each speaker.
Item 10 is the general public comment item
during which members of the public
may provide comment on matters
that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones
when you're not speaking.
Keep your cameras on at all times,
except during the schedule breaks
to ensure that we maintain a form
throughout today's virtual meeting.
If you do need to take a break,
turn off your camera and put a notice in the chat
so that we know who has left.
Try to be mindful that we wanna keep a form at all times,
so try to stagger any momentary breaks
that you need to take during the course of the meeting.
And then for each item on the agenda,
there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand
using the Zoom participant window
if you would like to ask a question or make a comment.
And with that, we're going to launch into item two,
which is the Every Student Succeeds Act
Authorization to Pursue Flexibility on
or Waiver of Assessment Accountability
and Reporting Requirements.
This item, as I noted, does have an addendum,
and the CDE is proposing that LEAs be allowed
to use the most viable option for assessment
in their local context,
including the Smarter Balanced Summit of Assessments
and Alternative Assessments for ELA and Mathematics
or other diagnostic benchmark or interim assessments.
And I will leave it to Rachel Maves and Mal Vang
to discuss all the details as they present the item.
Thank you, President Darlene Hammond.
Welcome, everyone.
It's good to see you all.
Superintendent Thurman, President Darlene Hammond,
and Board members.
I wanna just start today with a few framing remarks
as we come into this conversation about assessments
once again to help us situate ourselves in the context,
and then we'll go into the item in our slides.
And our hope is that this kind of walks
through the logic process of the proposal
that we're bringing before you today.
First, I just want to acknowledge some things from the heart
as a wise woman once told me.
The pandemic has and continues to shake our world.
Disrupting the ways in which we interact as humans,
while at the same time,
taking the lives of too many loved ones.
In the shaking, it has become clear that the persistent gaps
of inequitable access and opportunity
in our educational systems have become chasms.
While it may seem terribly out of place
to talk about annual assessments right now,
knowing the inequitable opportunities
in our systems pre-COVID intensifies the need
for us to assess and monitor student learning
to ensure we are targeting instruction
to best meet the needs of our most vulnerable students.
In this context, it seems not only appropriate,
but necessary.
Over the course of several months,
we have heard from a number of education leaders
and teachers, the traumatic impact and emotional toll
an entire year of distance learning has had on the lives
of our young people, school staff, and communities.
We also know that every student's experience
has been unique and that different parts of our state
have seen much greater impact than others.
At the same time, advocacy groups and policymakers
are asking for more information
to understand the impacts of the pandemic
on California students.
And parents in California and across the nation
have clearly expressed the need to understand
where their child is meeting
or not meeting grade level expectations.
We have tried to balance all of the concerns
clearly expressed by the field and stakeholders
to develop an approach that recognizes the reality
of education during the pandemic,
the need for educators to have sufficient data
to understand the learning gaps and disparities,
and the desire for parents to have information
regarding their child's learning.
The necessary flexibilities do not come without a cost.
What we gain in allowing LEAs to utilize
their locally chosen assessments,
we lose in the normal comparable test results we get
when all students take the same high quality assessment.
However, we believe it is the best option
during truly imperfect times.
With that, I'd like to turn the presentation
over to Dr. Mao Vang, and she will begin
to walk you through our item.
Thank you, Rachel.
Good afternoon, Superintendent Thurmond,
President Arlenham, and Board members.
I am Mao Vang, Director of the Assessment Development
and Administration Division
at the California Department of Education.
The item before you is both an action
and an information item.
And later in my presentation, Rachel Mays will rejoin me
and then we also have present to assist with questions,
Cindy Kazanis, who is the Director
of the Accountability Measurement and Reporting Division,
Jerry Winkler, Director of the Educational
Data Management Division, and Mary Arcella,
Executive Director of Educational Testing Service,
and Tony Alpert, Executive Director
of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
And with that, in today's presentation,
we will be covering the flexibilities offered
from the U.S. Department of Education,
a review of the California State Board of Education
or SBE's actions taken on February 24th,
our California's current context, stakeholder feedback,
and the California Department of Education
or CDE's recommendation to the State Board of Education.
This is a little bit busy,
but we'd like to recap our recommendation for you.
The California Department of Education, CDE,
recommends that the California State Board of Education,
SBE, delegate authority to CDE
and the SBE Executive Director
to prepare a general waiver to be submitted
to the U.S. Department of Education
to the extent necessary to include the following,
that the CDE is proposing that for the 2020-21 school year,
local educational agencies or LEAs be allowed
to use the most viable option for assessment
in their local context,
including the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
and California Alternate Assessments or CAAs
for English Language Arts or ELA and Mathematics
or other diagnostic benchmark or interim assessments
that are aligned with the California Common Core State
standards for English Language Arts and Mathematics
are viable to assess students in grades three through 11
and grades three through eight, excuse me,
and grade 11 are uniformly administered
across a grade span school or district
and provide results that can be reported to parents,
guardians, educators about individual students
and the public by school and by district
that are disaggregated by student group.
As a brief reminder,
we will start today with a quick overview
of the flexibilities offered
by the U.S. Department of Education.
So remember on February 22nd, 2021,
two days before the State Board of Education's meeting
in February, the Ed sent a letter to states indicating
that they can request a waiver to take advantage
of the full flexibilities offered by the Ed
for the 2020-21 school year with accountability
and school identification requirements
in the Elementary and Secondary Education Act or ESEA
as amended in the Every Student Succeeds Act or ESSA.
On March 8th, the Ed did release
the accountability waiver template
and states receiving this waiver
would not be required to implement
and report the results of their accountability system
that includes calculating progress toward long-term goals
and measurements of interim progress or indicators
and using data from the 2020-21 school year
to annually differentiate among its public schools
in a meaningful way.
Furthermore,
in addition, the states that are granted the waiver
would not be required to identify schools
for comprehensive support and improvement,
targeted support and improvement
and additional targeted support and improvement
based on data from the 2020-21 school year.
And they would be required to continue to support
to previously identify schools in the 2021-22 school year,
resume school identification in fall 2022,
and ensure transparency to parents and the public.
So as a condition of receiving the waiver,
the states will continue to publicly report
the segregated chronic absenteeism data for 2020-21.
So in addition to the flexibilities previously mentioned,
the Ed letter did indicate that other measures,
indicated other measures
to implement assessment flexibility.
These include administering a shortened version
of its statewide assessments,
offering remote administration where feasible,
feasible and or extending the testing window
to the greatest extent practicable.
So as noted during our previous board meeting,
California in a move to be proactive in meeting
LEAs needs for additional flexibilities
in the midst of this challenging year,
the State Board of Education approved the use
of the adjusted blueprints
for the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English Language Arts and Mathematics.
The timing of the approval,
which was in advance of the formal Ed guidance letter,
was required to allow sufficient time for our development
and for the development and implementation
as well as administration of assessments.
So with the SBE's approval in place,
the CDE directed our State Assessment Contractor, ETS,
to implement the adjusted forms
in the California assessment system.
The timeline of activities since November 2020 are as follow,
follows that in November 2020,
the State Board of Education approved
the adjusted Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English Language Arts and Mathematics blueprints,
so in November through December.
ETS and its subcontractor, Cambian,
removed the original ELA and mathematics forms
from the California assessment system.
And then in January through February,
systems testing with adjusted forms were conducted.
And then on February 22nd, 2021,
the adjusted Smarter Balanced ELA
and mathematics assessments were released to LEAs.
There's been a number of questions.
So I will just pause a little bit here
and just do a quick overview of what we have so far
in terms of testing at this point.
As of today, we do have roughly 14,000
of the Smarter Balanced ELA assessments
in the process of being administered.
There's 8,000 that have started
the Smarter Balanced summative assessments for math.
And then over 11,000 California science tests
that started with over 9,000 completed.
Roughly at this point in time,
there's 294,000 English Language Arts
and then 306,000 mathematics Smarter Balanced Interim
comprehensive assessments administered at this point.
And then from our analysis,
we found that it is clear many districts
are focusing on the administration
of the summative ALPAC with about 42% completed,
representing about over 420,000 English learners
at this point.
And this is approximately two times more
than the number of summative ALPAC administer in 2019,
which was the last year we had a full administration.
And at that time, the ALPAC was still paper pencil test,
the summative ALPAC.
So just to address some questions briefly from the field
to contrast the numbers in a normal year,
like in 2019, our last year of full implementation.
By March 15th, we have about roughly 43,000
Smarter Balanced English Language Arts tests in process
and about 19,000 in math a couple of years ago.
And then over 26,000 California Science tests in progress
and 24,000 completed about two years ago
at this point in time.
And then roughly 370,000 English Language Arts
and 350,000 Mathematics Smarter Balanced Interim
comprehensive assessments were administered
at this time in 2019.
So again, in 2019, the ALPAC was still a paper test
and we estimated that approximately 182,000 students
completed the summative ALPAC
based on the number of student documents
that our testing vendor received at that time.
And then this represented about 18% of our 2019
English learners eligible to take the summative ALPAC
at that time.
So the testing counts for English Language Arts
and Mathematics are slightly lower at this moment
compared to two years ago,
while testing counts for the ALPAC are much higher.
So I just wanted to bring a little recap
so that people could kind of see where we are
in testing at this point while I'm at this juncture.
Then moving forward in terms of continuing on
with the estimated testing times
for our Smarter Balanced Adjusted Forms that were approved.
As noted, we estimated that the adjusted forms
will reduce testing time for English Language Arts
and Mathematics by about one and a half to two hours,
depending on the grade level.
And then we focused on adjusting
the English Language Arts and Mathematics summative tests
because these tests impact the most students
and are also the longest test
compared to the other CASP assessments.
So it's important to note
that the students' tests are not timed.
LEAs have the authority to allow students
to take as much time as they need,
which helps them to demonstrate what they can do
if they could have as much time as they need.
And then students, as they begin to take a test
during a session on a particular day,
they can pause the test and restart it
right where they left off on a different day
in a different session if needed.
And these assessments are not necessary
to complete in one sitting.
So furthermore, the students,
if a student should lose connectivity during a test session,
the progress on their assessment will be saved
and students continue where they left off at a later time.
So trying to think about all these different supports
in terms of helping students to complete assessments,
that's how we came to the adjusted forms.
And in preparation for this adjusted forms,
in fall 2020, we were committed,
the CDE was committed to ensuring
that the flexible options
of the assessment administration,
when it became clear that most LEAs
would not be able to provide
in-person instruction for students.
We were committed to, we heard overwhelmingly
that the field need to
and have us realize the importance
of allowing additional time
to administer the optional summative ALPAC
for reclassification purposes.
The flexible options allow for LEAs
to administer the initial ALPAC starting last summer
and then the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments
where students were in-person or in remote.
And the LEAs did have the option to,
option of testing students in-person
following their local health and safety guidelines
and testing students remotely using our electronic,
the electronics and devices and tools that they did use,
that they are using for distance learning as well.
So these fall administrations led to multiple opportunities
for local educational agencies, the CDE and ETS
to engage in a collaborative discussion
regarding these assessment experience.
So using the feedback from the field,
we further refine and adjusted the processes
in preparation for the spring administration window.
So the feedback gave us a clear understanding
that students must use the secure browser
to take the assessments where,
whether it is in-person or remotely administered,
which provides the appropriate level of test security
allowing us to maintain the assessments validity
and reliability as much as possible.
So this collaborative work resulted
in adding integrated remote administration features
directly into the test delivery system.
The CDE engaged with LEAs and technology companies
such as Google and Apple and Microsoft in development
and testing of these embedded remote administration features
to ensure a platform that is responsive
to the needs of the students
and the test administrators or examiners
as we explore an entirely new process
and landscape for the administration of assessments.
This remote testing functionality
or these remote testing functionalities
include video monitoring, video calling and text messaging.
So the test examiners and test administrators
can view students testing in real time by video
while also monitoring each student's progress
through the tests.
The video feed is similar to the grid of thumbnails
of an online meeting application,
like what we're doing now.
And as in previous administrations,
the test administrator and test examiners
can pause a student's test at any time,
whether they are conducting a remote
or in-person administration.
So the test administrators and examiners
and the student can communicate directly with each other
through the test delivery system
by a one-to-one video call or text message.
Again, test administrators and examiners
can also send out a broadcast message
to all students in the testing session.
So videos showing these remote administration processes
are available on the CASP ALPAC YouTube channel.
And I just want to highlight that it's important to know
that based on the current data for instructional modes,
the majority of LEAs continue to be in distance learning.
So although there are many returning,
there's still the need for distance learning support.
So the remote administration of assessments,
whether we are doing summative, interim,
or local assessments will need to continue to be an option.
CDE and ETS will continue to provide real-time support
for remote administration of the summative
and interim assessments through email.
They could email our California Technical Support Center
at calcaltactacats.org
or phone the 800 number at 800-955-2954
and have live chats at the websites at caaspp.org
and elpac.org, the CASP and ALPAC websites.
So these remote administration
or remote administration was provided
for the optional summative ALPAC in the fall,
as I had mentioned earlier,
and the 2020-21 initial ALPAC in the fall.
And we have a full report of the results
of the psychometric analysis conducted
with the summative ALPAC,
and that is posted on our CDE ALPAC webpage
under our technical documents section
at the link provided in the SBE March item addendum.
So at this point, on the following slides,
I will be recapping the motions that were made
by the SBE on February 24th,
and we will quickly review the five motions.
Here, just to recap, the motion one
was that the SBE directed CDE
to prepare a waiver consistent with the federal template
regarding the flexibilities offered by Ed
for accountability and school identification,
which includes decoupling the accountability
from this year's assessments
and waiving the requirement
that the academic achievement indicator, excuse me,
be adjusted to account
for a participation rate below 95% as applicable.
Motion two was to extend the 2020-21
test administration window for both the CASP and ALPAC
to July 30, 2021 as applicable,
and then motion three direct CDE
to prepare a general waiver
of the California Science Test
for the 2020-21 school year.
Motion four, create a policy means
to provide assessment information for this year
to parents, educators, and the public,
and delegate authority to the State Board of Education
Executive Director in collaboration with CDE staff
to develop a waiver proposal to bring back to the board
that focuses on a plan for assessments
that provide data to parents, educators, and the public,
which monitors the progress of students in ELA and math,
and that will propose a means
for uniform reporting of that data
in both aggregated and disaggregated forms.
Excuse me, sorry, I have.
So I will review the motion,
specifically in motion one,
we have, again, as the,
in terms of the flexibilities,
motion one directed the CDE to prepare a waiver
that is consistent with the template
regarding the flexibilities offered by Ed
for accountability and school identification,
which includes the decoupling and accountability
from this year's assessments,
and waiving the requirement
that the academic achievement indicator
be adjusted to account for participation
below 95% as applicable.
So this action relieves states of the requirement
to identify comprehensive support and improvement,
targeted support and improvement,
and additional targeted support and improvement schools,
and removes the consequences associated
with not meeting the 95% participation rate.
So federal law requires 95% participation rate
in both, participation in both assessment
and accountability at the state, district,
school, and student group levels.
Accountability requirements tied to the 95% participation rate
to the academic achievement indicator.
The Ed waived the tie to the academic achievement indicator,
but not the requirement to assess the 95% of students.
Therefore, the 95% requirements still stands,
but there is no penalty if LEAs are unable to meet it.
So it's important, it is important regardless
of the assessment use that each LEA strive
to ensure each student has the opportunity
to prepare and participate in assessments
to inform teaching and learning.
So the CDE is currently preparing
the accountability waiver template, as I mentioned,
that was released by Ed on March 8th, 2021.
It will submit it to Ed in keeping with the SBE action
at the February meeting.
So to ensure continued alignment
with the federal and state accountability systems,
the next step will be to request legislative action
to remove the state accountability requirements,
and this would include a request
to waive the requirement to produce data indicators
on the California school dashboard,
and pause identification of LEAs
for differentiated assistance based on data
from the 2020-21 school year.
Motion two, the second motion extended
the 2020-21 test administration window
for both the CASP and LPAC to July 30, 2021 as applicable.
So during the SBE meeting on February 24,
the Board discussed three options
regarding the assessment window.
One option was no changes, keep the current regulations,
which state and LEA's CASP assessment window
will end on the last day of instruction,
or July 15, whichever comes sooner,
or for those administering the LPAC,
it would be May 31.
Option two was to extend the window to July 30
for the CASP and LPAC,
or option three was to end the testing windows
per current assessment regulations
and add a new fall summative CASP and LPAC testing window
that could be made available
from about August 15 through October 29.
After careful deliberation,
the Board chose to take action
on extending assessment windows through July 30, 2021.
So to meet this action,
the CDE has prepared emergency regulations
for both the CASP and the LPAC
extending the testing windows,
and this is item five in the March 2021 SBE agenda.
If an LEA's last day of instruction is May,
for example, or beginning in June,
this option will potentially add additional six to eight
weeks to the assessment window.
While the expectation is not to bring students
in over the summer solely to assess,
it provides the opportunity for LEAs to assess students
who are provided targeted instruction over the summer months
in accordance with the California Assembly Bill 86.
If feasible and appropriate,
assessments could be administered during this time.
As discussed during the Board meeting on the 24th,
a decision regarding the extension of the assessment window
needed to be made at that time
to ensure that our contractors could develop
and prepare the necessary infrastructure for administration.
As such, the option for fall administration
or a fall assessment window no longer exists.
The third motion directed the CDE
to prepare a general waiver
of the California Science Test for the 2020-21 school year.
The intent of this SBE motion passed on February 24, 2021
was to waive all statewide science assessments.
This is both the California Science Test
and the California Alternate Assessment for Science.
So with the approval of this motion,
the SBE has directed the CDE to pursue a waiver
to provide additional flexibility from testing to LEAs.
As a reminder,
the administration of statewide science assessments
is required by state and federal laws.
The CDE will prepare requests for waivers
from both state and federal
statewide science assessment requirements.
The fourth and fifth motions are being combined.
Motion four was for the CDE to create a policy means
to provide assessment information this school year
to parents, educators, and the public.
Motion five delegated authority
to the State Board of Education Executive Director
in collaboration with the CDE staff
to develop a waiver proposal to bring back to the board
that focuses on a plan for assessment
that provides data to parents, educators, and the public,
which monitors the progress of students
in English language arts and mathematics,
and that will provide or propose a means
for uniform reporting of that data
in both aggregated and disaggregated forms.
So the CDE is incorporating the response to motion four
as part of the plan outlined in motion five.
The focus of today's item and the recommendation
are to meet the requests
from the State Board of Education
as outlined in this motion.
And with that, I'm going to pause and turn it over
to Rachel Maves, our Deputy Superintendent
of Public Instruction of the Instruction
and Measurement Branch, Rachel.
Thank you, Dr. Vang.
So before we jump into California's current context,
I wanted to just create a little bit of the,
an understanding of the why.
As Dr. Vang laid out, ED provided us,
and I think you heard it at the last board meeting,
and then coming into this board meeting,
some flexibilities that we as California
had already taken advantage of.
We shortened the blueprint,
we provided remote administration,
and we've taken action to extend the assessment we go.
And then the board took it a step further even
by allowing a waiver for a science assessment
and then recognize the need that it still wasn't enough.
There was still more that we were going to have to do.
And as we come into California's current context
and the feedback that we hear from stakeholders,
I think that is something that you will hear very clearly
that in all these efforts that we've made over and beyond,
there's still more that we need to address.
So we're gonna go into California's current context now.
Next slide.
Just a minute.
It did this last time too.
Perfect.
So California, as many of you know,
has the largest and most diverse student population
in the United States.
We have more than 6 million students
that attend kindergarten through grade 12,
and nearly half of these students speak a language
other than English at home.
More than 300,000 teachers work
in approximately 10,000 schools.
And over 1,000 districts with student populations
ranging from four to 590,000 students.
Roughly 4.2 million students are assessed annually.
Next slide.
What we'd like to discuss today
and give you a little bit of a picture,
not only is California a diverse state,
but we are also in the midst of transitioning
from full-time in-person instruction to hybrid
to distance learning only and back and forth.
On January 25th, we began asking districts,
charter schools and private schools
to submit their instructional status by school type.
Consistent with health guidance,
we are seeing more in-person instruction,
full-time and hybrid at the elementary level
than the middle or high school level.
And we're gonna get into some maps here
pretty quickly that show that.
But I think it's important to note
that during the novel coronavirus for 2019 pandemic,
California LEAs have been balancing
the learning needs of students
and the challenges of planning for public safety
while considering their local circumstances.
LEAs have provided instruction through various models,
including in-person instruction,
distance learning and hybrid.
However, a vast majority of students
are not yet attending class in person,
but we're moving in that direction.
Next slide.
What you see before you is the GIS mapping
to display primary mode of instruction
that allows the visualization
of how instruction is being provided across the state.
This is publicly accessible on the California ALL website
for safe schools reopening.
What you're seeing, the dark blue
are the district boundaries
that reflect schools that are in-person,
or districts that are in-person
within the district boundaries.
Hybrid is light blue,
and then yellow is distance learning only,
and the white is no status available.
Next slide, ma'am.
On this side, you'll see that charter schools
are shown by school location.
Again, the dark blue reflects the in-person instruction,
the light blue reflects hybrid,
and the yellow presents distance learning.
Next slide.
On March 8th, we'll begin asking for planned reopening dates.
We are seeing an increase in the number of districts
with planned reopening dates in March and April,
and expect 7,000 schools to be opened by the end of March.
On March 22nd, we will begin collecting
school-level information
by student count pursuant of AB 86.
Next slide.
So in addition to the challenges faced
as LEAs transition back to in-person instruction,
many for the first time in over a year,
for the first time in over a year,
technology also continues to be a barrier.
600,000 to 1 million students do not have access
to quality high-speed internet connectivity at home.
Even despite $2.1 billion of learning loss mitigation funds
were spent on technology.
And based on a recent survey about devices being used,
student, by students, over 376,000 students
are using unmanaged Chromebooks.
This is significant because in a normal year,
96% of all of our assessments happen on Google devices.
Traditionally, students have used and shared devices
that are wheeled around from classroom to classroom
on carts for assessments.
And this year, however, and I would say
it's actually one of the bright spots
that came out of COVID,
the majority of students have,
for the first time in California history,
access to a device.
This feat has been accomplished through the many efforts
of the state of California,
including those of our state superintendent
in his relentless effort to close the digital divide.
And over the course of the past few months,
CDE has worked diligently with our testing vendor
and with Google to secure options
that would allow access to the secure browser
and are in continued discussion
about how we might mitigate these issues.
But again, 376,000 students
are using the unmanaged Chromebooks
and do not have access to the secure browser
without this fix.
Next slide.
So that creates a little bit of the context
of what California is facing in the midst of the pandemic.
We also continue to hear feedback from stakeholders.
Meeting the needs of a state as diverse as California
is complex and nuanced in a normal year.
The previous slides provided us a high level overview
of the current context of our state.
The following slides incorporate the context
from the voice of our stakeholders.
Next slide.
The discussion regarding assessments
has been a dividing factor among groups,
not just in California, but across the nation.
Prior to our meeting on the 24th,
there was a wide range of divergence perspectives
about spring assessments.
On one end, there was a clear cry to waive the requirement
for all statewide assessments for the 2021 school year.
And on the other side, an adamant need
to ensure a clear understanding of the impact
on student learning during the pandemic.
In the last few weeks, there has been a coalescence
around a few common themes.
Recent letters provided the following input.
Across the board, there is a strong interest
in receiving valid data regarding how students have fared
and to identify areas of learning loss or gaps.
Some stakeholders want summative assessments
to inform student learning and address learning loss.
Yet it continues to surface,
we continue to see the issues that are persistent
with bandwidth, internet access,
and inconsistent testing environments,
complicated by efforts to transition students back
to in-person instruction.
Some stakeholders request the suspension
of the requirement for this administration
of the statewide annual standardized summative assessments,
and then others are asking for an option for LEAs
to use local and or interim assessments.
This is where we're starting to coalesce.
Everyone agrees, results should be provided
to parents and guardians,
as well as made publicly available
to the school and LEA level.
Next slide.
Recently, CDE conducted a brief survey asking LEAs
what assessments they had in place
as outlined underneath SB 98.
The survey revealed the following.
We had 969 unique LEAs respond to the survey.
It was administered on March 5th, 2021.
And what we see is that approximately 77% of respondents
indicated that they have used the following five
local assessments during the 2021 school year.
STAR assessments by Renaissance,
iReady by Curriculum Associates,
Measures of Academic Progress by NWEA,
Fast Bridges by Illuminate,
and Reading Inventory by Hoot Mifflin Harcourt.
A little over 60% is comprised of the top three,
STAR, iReady, and MAP.
About 19% of the respondents indicated
that they have used another local assessment.
The majority of those who responded
that they have used other local assessments
indicated that they are using
the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments
or Locally Developed Assessments.
Next slide.
In order to fulfill the request outlined by the Board
in Motion 5, taking into consideration
California's current context,
as well as the feedback provided by stakeholders
across the state, CDE is proposing
that for the 2021 school year,
LEAs be allowed to use the most viable option
for assessments in their local context,
including the Smarter Balanced Semitive Assessments
and CAAs, the alternate assessments for ELA and math,
or other diagnostic benchmark or interim assessments
that are aligned with the Common Core State Standards
for ELA and math are available to assess students
in grades three through eight and grade 11,
are uniformly administered
across a grade span school or district,
and provide results that can be reported
to parents, guardians, educators
about individual students into the public
by school and by district,
and are disaggregated by student group.
Next slide, Mel.
While the proposal presented today
is specific to ELA and math,
we want to briefly discuss the other assessments.
While California will pursue a general waiver for the CAS
and the CAA for science,
the science test will continue to be available
for any LEA to use during the 2021 school year.
It is voluntary and it is their choice,
but we will continue to make that available.
In addition, all English learners must be administered
the summative LPAC according
to the English Learner Fact Sheet Addendum Guidance
that the ED provided on January 18th, 2021.
The requirement for the summative has not
and will not be waived.
Next slide.
We also wanted to highlight a few considerations
that LEA should make as they're deciding
which assessment is going to best suit their needs
should the Board choose to move forward
with this recommendation.
While the CDE understands
that summative test administration of any kind
may be challenging,
these points are again,
ones that we want to bring to a high level.
Providing the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for ELA and math to students in grade 11
will support the California State University
early assessment program requirements.
It's important as high school districts
and unified districts are making this consideration
that they consider the 11th grade summative
as the lead indicator for assessing school student readiness
for CSU courses.
Other indicators include GPA and course grades.
And over the last few months,
it has been noted there is an increase
in the number of D's and F's students are receiving
at times for behavior reasons
that do not reflect student learning.
To be clear, it is not a mandate
to provide the summative to 11th grade students.
That's not what we're proposing,
but should be a consideration
in the decision making process.
Additionally, using the Smarter Balanced
summative assessments for ELA and math
will allow students to access
the extensive universal tools,
designated supports and accommodations,
which they are familiar with as needed.
Many of the accessibility resources available to students
are built into assessment systems as tools,
including Zoom, a universal tool that make text
and graphics larger by selecting the Zoom in button.
Masking, a designated support
that involves blocking off content
that is not of immediate need to the student
so they're able to focus on a specific part
of the test item, an American sign language
and closed captioning.
Again, not a mandate, but just things
that should be taken into consideration
that are available for the summative assessment.
And then finally, the last consideration
is that per state and federal statutes,
LEAs will still be required to publicly report,
disaggregated data disaggregated by student group
in the School Accountability Report Card, or the SARC,
and the Local Educational Agency Report Card, or LAR,
the performance of students by assessment
and the number and percentage of students
tested and not tested.
Finally, we just want to share with the Board
some of our next steps should we move forward from today.
CDE will and is committed to releasing CASP
and LPAC summative assessment results
when ready and appropriate
when we are finished with assessments,
provide guidance for public reporting to LEAs
that did not administer the summative assessments,
continue to support the field
by providing office hours and coffee sessions.
We have a meeting already scheduled for next week
to give a debrief and overview of the assessments
and the things discussed at the Board today,
and then also to develop clarification
through frequently asked questions
that we will publicly post.
Last slide, Mal.
So finally, we come back to our revised recommendation.
The California Department of Education recommends
that the California State Board of Education
delegate authority to CDE and or the SBE Executive Director
to prepare a general waiver to be submitted
to U.S. Department of Education to the extent necessary
to include the following.
The CDE again is proposing to meet all of the current context
that we have not yet been able to do so far,
that for the 2021 school year,
LEAs be allowed to use the most viable option
for assessment in their local context,
including the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
and CAAs for ELA and math,
or other diagnostic benchmark or interim assessments
that are again aligned with the California
Common Core State Standards for ELA and math,
are available to assess students
in grades three through eight in grade 11,
are uniformly administered
across the grade span school or district,
and provide results that can be reported
to parents, guardians, educators about individual students
and to the public by school and district
and are disaggregated by student groups.
At this point, I'll turn it back over
to President Darlene Hammond for any clarifying questions.
Thank you very much.
I just wanna express a great appreciation to Rachel,
to Mao, to all the members of the staff
who have really dug in on the research,
on the possibilities, conducting surveys,
reaching out to the field,
responding to stakeholder questions
to get us to this moment of being able
to consider these possibilities.
I'm going to ask Member Sun
as one of our assessment liaisons
if she has initial comments,
then we'll see if there are any clarifying questions
before we turn to public comment.
Yeah, just-
Member Sun.
Thank you.
So yeah, to echo President Darlene Hammond's comments
as well, just great thanks to both Rachel Maves
and Mao Feng for all of their work and leadership in this.
This is not easy, I know,
and you've done a tremendous job,
as President Darlene Hammond said,
doing the research, trying to make this balanced
of the flexibility and also address some of the concerns
around ensuring that we get data
to look at any exacerbated inequities
that we have experienced during this pandemic.
So I don't have much else to add to this,
look forward to the conversation
with the rest of the Board.
And again, just really appreciate the recommendations
that we've landed here today
to allow that flexibility for LEAs.
That's great.
And I'm going to see if,
I think we probably ought to put up the public comment slide
so people can begin to see the number
as they queue up for public comment.
I'm gonna see if there's any clarifying questions
at this time, I see Member Strauss.
And let's keep it to clarifying questions now
because we'll have plenty of time for discussion later.
So Vice President Strauss and Member Burr.
My question, again, thank you so much for the presentation.
Just my quick clarifying question,
should this be approved today, Deputy Superintendent Mays,
we would, I assume, submit then to ED,
when do we expect to hear back
that if the waiver would be approved
and then when will districts know that it is okay
to move ahead with our recommendation?
That, I'm gonna have to get back to you on a timeline
for that, Member Strauss.
We've had multiple conversations now with ED
and we're starting conversations with ledge staff.
Everyone understands the urgency of this,
and so we will be moving forward as quickly as possible.
And Member Burr.
Thank you.
And I will associate myself with the comments on my call.
I'll associate myself with the comments on my colleagues
about my great appreciation to Rachel and your staff
for listening carefully to our conversation
at our previous meeting
and really doing some hard work
to get to this recommendation.
My specific question is,
of the five assessments that were identified by the LEAs,
can you tell me,
are those assessments given in the same grade levels
as the Smarter Balanced assessments,
or are they different and if so, how?
Thank you.
So I'll share what my understanding of that is
and then, Mao, perhaps if you're available
to jump in as well.
But my understanding for those assessments
is that they are available K through 12.
Mao, is that your understanding as well?
I think some specific ones may not have high school level,
but most of them are at least elementary
and middle school available.
Yeah, they differ across assessments,
but most cover most grades.
Yes.
Any other clarifying questions?
Okay, so we want to open up to public comment
and the public comment slide is up
and so we want to encourage any commenters
to state their name and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computers
if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, currently we have 22 on the line.
Callers, just a quick reminder, this is for item two only.
Again, we are only taking calls for item two only.
Caller, you are now live.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, I'm Dave Dabrowski,
the Assistant Superintendent of Education Services
for Harupa Unified School District in Riverside County.
I speak today to support moving forward with this request
to waive the requirement for CASP summative testing
for the school year.
As you know, many districts are engaged in the process
of returning to in-person instruction, which is wonderful,
but it's also a process that takes a huge amount
of energy, resources, and adaptation for districts,
teachers, students, and parents.
This layers in more complexity to get in the way
of successfully implementing the CASP testing process.
In addition, our district, like many others,
uses diagnostic assessments, which can be disaggregated
and reported to parents and the public
in lieu of CASP results.
And while we recognize it's been difficult
to not be able to take our students' temperature
with a quality standardized assessment for the past year,
we also know that using a thermometer inaccurately
will yield inaccurate results and won't serve
the greater good for our students and families
in the way that our local diagnostic assessments would.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Yeah, good afternoon.
This is Michael McCormick,
Superintendent of the Val Verde Unified School District.
I would just echo the previous caller's comments.
Michael Fullin says, you know, this is the time for us
to strengthen our internal accountability processes.
We have those in place,
and I would strongly encourage the board
to allow us the option to use
our internal accountability measures,
which can be reported to students and parents,
and also reported by student groups.
Thank you for today's opportunity to speak.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Yes, you're live.
My name is Gloria Ulloa-Robriguez,
board member of the California Association
for Bilingual Education, Yolo Woodlands, chapter 76.
Our chapter would like to express our concern
that English language learners
who have been under an immense level of stress
are being forced to take tests.
With the many obstacles they have faced,
we question the validity and reliability
of tests taken under these conditions.
Online learning for these students has been inequitable
with the inconsistent access to digital device
or the internet, limited understanding of English,
and limited ability to work independently without support.
English language learners should not have to miss
vital instruction they need because of standardized testing.
We do not want them to have time taken away
from instruction during the pandemic.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Mercedes Levy,
and I'm the associate superintendent
in Oceanside Unified School District.
We serve over 16,500 students, PK through grade 12,
including military-connected students and children
whose families work in agriculture.
As we consider the best way to support our students,
it's essential that assessment plans
consume the need for action, accountability, and equity.
Local assessments in our district
provide us with the opportunity
to assess students throughout the year.
This is especially important to our military
and migrant families whose children often move
from school to school within the same year.
Our local assessments allow us to assess students
when they enroll, report to families about a child's needs
and develop an action plan within hours.
Local assessments ensure accountability
by enabling us to report student progress
by student groups and for individual students.
Local assessments allow us to effectively monitor
and adjust the instructional program to meet student needs.
I urge you to accept the recommendation
to use local assessments to ensure action,
accountability, and equitable plans for students
rather than one-year tests.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Okay, this is Samuel Erd.
I am a 10-year-old special needs student in Fontana.
I believe we do not need any more waivers
for testing at this point.
Please do not create any more waivers
to reduce accountability for these assessments.
By maintaining all these assessments as required,
we will learn the actual impact that COVID had on all students.
Today, I ask to call from the State Board of Education
to protect special children.
Please put no on any waivers.
Please follow me at the YouTube movement,
everything successful in educational affiliation,
social education, social matters.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Thank you.
This is Andrea Ball on behalf of the Orange County
Department of Education.
I want to thank the CDE staff for all the outreach
in putting together this proposal.
We signed on to the coalition letter
and do support allowing the use of local interim assessments
rather than requiring annual standardized summative assessments.
Schools are bringing more students back to campuses.
They're focused on that now.
Across the diverse county,
across the diverse county,
there has been an impact on student mental health and stress.
We think using local assessments to inform instruction
and improvement are much better use
of everyone's time and effort.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Dr. Darla Hammond and board members.
Diana Liu representing the Association
of California School Administrators.
We'd like to thank the board
and the California Department of Education staff
for the thoughtful work
that has gone into the assessment flexibility request.
I actually believe CDE's recommendation
with the safety and well-being of students first
while also ensuring student progress and data
can be evaluated towards the parents,
educators and the public by providing LEAs
the flexibility to use the most viable option
for assessments in their local context,
including local assessments.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Katie Summer, assistant superintendent
for UCI Unified School District.
LEAs should be allowed to use the most viable option
for assessment in their local context,
including interim assessments.
Our Common Core Aligned Interim Assessments
allow us to measure learning loss.
We administer the assessments three to four times a year
and have prior year data
that will help us measure learning loss.
In addition, we're able to create reports
for parents, students and the public.
Additionally, our data can be disaggregated
by subgroup using our platform
and our student information systems.
Again, please allow us the flexibility
to use our local interim assessments this year
in lieu of mandated federal
and state testing requirements.
Furthermore, we strongly support the waiving
of the California Science Test.
Both actions will help us maximize
in-person instructional time.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
This is Carlos Machado
with California School Board Association.
We too would like to thank the board and its staff
for all the work on this item.
CSBA is also a signer onto the coalition letter
to request the use of local assessments
which also seeks a waiver of the state
federal testing requirements.
We think the proposal before you achieves that balance
and we appreciate your consideration of this item.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Darlene Hammond and members.
This is Eric Premack
with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We'll also associate us with the comments,
thanking staff and the board
for your careful consideration.
We're fine with the pending proposal in front of you.
We do, however, hope that you'll urge
the Newsome administration and legislature
to suspend the high-stakes test-based charter renewal laws
until we have at least a few years
of quote unquote normal assessment data under our belt.
We also hope that you all extend the type of flexibility
you're contemplating here to the administration
of the so-called verified data sources
that charter schools are supposed to use
for renewal purposes,
including flexing the 95% participation expectation
and allowing for remote administration,
which the current rules do not allow.
So we hope you'll consider all of that
as part of this package.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Verlin-Hammond
and members of the board.
I'm Jennifer Hicks, Assistant Superintendent
of Educational Services
at the Plata County Office of Education
and the 2021 SISC Chair.
I'm sharing these comments on behalf of SISC and CSFS.
We support the CDE's recommendation to pursue a waiver
for the required administration
of the state standardized assessments
and allow LEAs to use the most viable option
for assessment in their local context,
whether that be the Smarter Balanced Submitted Assessments
or other diagnostic benchmarks
or interim assessments being used at the local level.
These local assessments continue to be used
to identify learning loss and guidelines
for learning acceleration.
They provide a meaningful way for LEAs
to not only inform instruction and learning acceleration,
but also report student progress
to current stakeholders in the public.
I also wanna thank the CDE staff
for their thoughtful recommendations
and ongoing engagement with the field.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Enrique Rocha
and I'm here representing
the San Diego Unified School District.
And I'm calling to express support
for the flexibility to use local assessments
to fulfill state requirements.
In San Diego Unified,
we are planning on the use of BAS for ALA and MAP
and also the district essential MAP indicators
for grade six through 12.
As we prepare for a return to in-person instruction,
this flexibility will be essential.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
This is Beverly Eidman
on behalf of the ACSA Curriculum Instruction
and Accountability Council
and the King City Union School District.
I also would like to implore the board
to consider the flexibility
that has been proposed by Rachel Mason's staff.
Our local districts need the flexibility
to make this decision as we begin to transition
from distance learning to hybrid.
When we are finally back in person,
we will have part of our population still
in the distance learning mode
in spite of having hotspots for every student.
We're having connectivity issues for these students
and our local assessments have been very successful
and utilizing our iReady assessments
in an ongoing manner will allow us to really find,
to fine tune where we need to focus our instruction
in the summer and going into the fall.
We believe that this is in the best interest of students
as we begin this transition to allow for
the potential emotional learning.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Mary Ann Grosner, I'm a parent.
The state has already taken steps towards flexibility.
They shortened the Smarter Balanced Testing
for English and Math back in November 2020
and offer LEA's remote administration of CAHPS and LPAC.
As you are aware, case rates are dropping
and more and more of the community
has access to the vaccines.
We are looking at returning our kids back to school
full time in the very near term.
Creating more flexibilities or waivers
seems like we're taking a step backwards.
With more than six billion students attending
California K through 12 schools
and nearly half of whom speak a language
other than English at home,
providing education is so extremely important.
Let's not create any more waivers
to reduce the accountability for these assessments.
English language learners and all students deserve better.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, my name is Crystal Diaz
from Californians Together
and the following is a message that we received
from a teacher in Los Angeles Unified School District
who wanted her words shared with the board
as she is currently teaching remotely.
I truly hope that the board makes the right decision.
Right now I am grappling with having to administer
the ALPAC reading inventory, IAVs and tasks
all within the next two months.
When do we teach?
Especially during this pandemic when many of our teachers
only see their students twice a week.
It is unrealistic.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is, good afternoon.
My name is Emily McGinnis,
Director of Data Analysis and Accountability
for Campbell Union School District.
Like other LEAs, we have local measures
whose results can be communicated to families
in the public, disaggregated by student groups
and provide a consistent measure for reporting out
and acting upon student learning loss.
I speak today in support of the waiver
as flexibility and use of local assessments allow LEAs
to focus on supporting our students'
socio-emotional well-being
as they return to in-person learning.
Now more than ever, flexibility and attention
to the current local context is essential.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is David Arias,
father of three kids in special needs.
I believe I don't need any more waivers
for testing at this point.
Please don't create any more waivers
to reduce accountability for these assessments
by maintaining all assessments required.
Today I ask the California State Board of Education
to protect special children.
Please vote no for any waivers.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello?
Yes, you're live.
I'm live?
Yes, please go ahead with your time.
I'm sorry.
I didn't have a number.
Hi, this is Susan Nisman with Speak Up Parents,
United Parents in Los Angeles.
And I want to thank the board and the staff for their work
in coming to some consensus and agreement on how best
to assess the learning loss as our children return
to school and looking at it as a teaching
tool for our teachers and educators and parents
in terms of understanding that the value
of these assessments is that they are made
they they're not they're not to be punitive
and they won't be used to limit student access
to grade level coursework and that all schools
and stakeholders understand that the logistics
are participating in the assessments
and that this must be communicated
so that it's understood that this is all information
that's being gathered for the purpose
of understanding what resources identifying
where these gaps come from.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hi, can you hear me?
Yes.
Hi.
Good afternoon board president and members of the board.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of the Riverside County
Superintendent of Schools and the 23 School District
Superintendents of Riverside County.
Our educational leaders joined a coalition
of education management and educators
to request the board to pursue a waiver
for the required state test for the current school year.
We believe that staff's recommendation
address our concerns and allow LEAs the flexibility
to determine which is the most feasible option
for assessments based on their local context.
Thank you very much for all this hard work.
Thank you caller.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, I'm Mrs.
Loya. I'm a San Bernardino teacher.
I don't agree with having waivers for testing.
Assessing helps us know how much student has learned.
Let's not create more waivers.
We already reduced their learning time.
Let's help our students stay away
protected from any waivers.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Yeah, good afternoon to the board.
My name is Lisa Bennett.
I'm a special education teacher in LA USD.
The emotional struggles, pressure and demands
on our students during crisis distance learning
has been monumental.
I have not been with my students
in a physical space for one year now.
I have new students in my class
that I've never met in person.
The requirement for a statewide assessment
is absolutely the last thing students need
in their lives at this time.
They are surviving a pandemic.
The data will not be valid or reliable,
nor will it guide my instruction.
In addition, accommodations for students with disabilities
as written in the IEP are not feasible
in a remote environment.
I would like our school district
to be able to use local assessments.
Let's not continue to put unnecessary pressure
on our students.
They've suffered enough.
They've done the best they can under the circumstances.
A test does not reflect all they have accomplished
during this year.
Nothing has been standardized
in how we've been educating our students this year,
so a test should not be standardized either.
I urge you to use local recommendations.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, Madam President and members of the board.
This is Brian Revis calling on behalf
of the Education Trust West.
We continue to believe that proceeding
with statewide summative assessments is the best option,
and that's primarily because we think that's the best way
to see what happened to student learning
during the pandemic and provide actionable data.
If you proceeded with the summative assessments,
some of the issues that have been laid out
in the staff report would be addressed,
including ensuring assessments are standards aligned,
that there are accommodations for English language learners,
and that there is uniform reporting.
At the same time, we see that you may be open
to local assessments.
If you proceed with that option
or providing the flexibility for local assessments,
we recommend that there be strong guidance issued
by the Department of Education,
and that would include providing a list
of approved assessments to ensure...
Thank you, your time has ended.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please list your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Robert Mann.
We're in calling from Children Now.
We worked with the Ed Trust West
to write a coalition letter that included equity groups,
parent groups, and business groups.
So I'll associate my comments with the previous speaker.
Wanted to build out a couple of things.
One is, to the extent that you use a local assessment,
that you provide some quality guardrails,
particularly around accommodation and supports
for English learners and special needs students.
And in terms of reporting the data,
since most of the school districts
are likely to use a small list of tools,
we would suggest providing some standardized reporting
that would be reported out to the states
for the local education agency report cards.
And finally, we systematically oppose the waiver for science.
All the major issues that California faces right now,
a pandemic, wildfire seasons that we've had...
Thank you, caller.
They all depend upon...
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Caller, are you on the line?
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz,
representing the California Association
for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We support the use of local district assessments,
but requests that the motion include
referencing designated supports and accommodations
to be made available to students who are taking the CAS
for Mathematics and English Language Arts,
and that districts use these accessibility strategies
as they have implemented in the past
to the best of their abilities,
including providing bilingual versions
of the mathematics assessments.
These designated supports and accommodations
increase equitable access to assessments by all students
and allow students to show what they know and can do.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and board members.
This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We support the approach recommended
by the department today in the addendum.
We urge the board to be explicit about
and direct the department to communicate clearly
to LEAs and the public that social, emotional supports
and expanded learning activities
should be prioritized over test prep,
and that the purpose of testing
is to provide actionable information to parents,
educators, and the public
so that they can program services and actions
in expanded learning session or the next year.
The overriding need at this time
is for LEAs to assess and respond
to the needs of those of their students
that have been disproportionately affected
by the COVID-19 pandemic.
Any waiver requests to the U.S. Department of Ed
should be conditioned on assurances
that this level of accountability will take place,
and we suggest for specific student groups
that are identified by local data.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, my name is Lucero Chavez
speaking on behalf of the Parent Institute
for Quality Education, or FECN,
a national family engagement organization
founded in San Diego.
As students and some assessments are made,
we urge the board to keep our families in mind,
many of whom are still struggling
to mitigate their students' learning loss
due to the ongoing pandemic.
We urge the board to direct CDE to communicate clearly
to LEAs and our families that social, emotional support
and expanded learning activities
should be prioritized over test preparation,
and that the purpose of testing
is only to inform upcoming programming and services.
We would like to highlight the need
for home language communication,
one-to-one modes of communication,
specifically for eligible students and their families,
and modes of communication that are accessible
and culturally responsible to families' needs.
Thank you to board and staff for your work
on how to help our students and their families.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, this is Maria Arias.
I am the founder of the YouTube movement
Every Student Successful,
More Education, Less Mitigation,
and I'm here also to speak
on behalf of special education community.
I have three children with special needs,
and I believe that the LEAs or schools
do not need any more waivers for testing at this point.
We really need to learn how the COVID-19 pandemic
has affected education,
and we need the assessment to be required as is
so we can learn what the actual impact was on all students.
So today, I ask the California State Board of Education
to protect all children,
including special education children.
So please vote no on any waivers
and kindly support our special ed children
by following us on the YouTube movement.
Thank you very much for your support.
Have a great day.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, state board members.
My name is Sheila Whitley,
and I'm representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA strongly recommends that the state board adopt
the CDE's recommended action in the addendum
for item two with one caveat.
CTA believes that the CDE and SBE
must clearly communicate to the field
that the SBAC would not be required
and that appropriate diagnostic benchmark
or interim assessments can and should be used
to provide data to parents, educators, and the public.
Over 60,000 teachers and community members
have signed our petition to waive state tests
and to continue to plead their case
as the importance of spending more time
on the mental and emotional health of our students
and the academic needs that they have.
CTA stands ready to support the efforts
of the CDE and SBE to fulfill the requirements
under the waiver proposal.
Thank you, caller.
Your time's ended.
Thank you for the implementation
across the state.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Lorraine Richards speaking as a parent.
Please consider students being first
for valued instruction and not use them
for the sheer factor of getting data
that we already know what it will state.
The use of local assessments allows the LEA
to choose the tests that will work
for their population during these times
and what the population is most familiar with.
If we have learned anything during these times
are what is possible.
Therefore, make it possible to allow the professionals
to choose what the best fit is for their population.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Everybody in my family, by the end of the month,
will have the time.
Caller, you're live.
Yeah, hopefully my sister can get it.
Me and my mom, we're looking.
Caller, you're live at the State Board of Education.
Oh, hi.
My name is Janet Ilko.
I am with the Health Sciences High Middle College
and I am calling in support of making sure
that all of our students,
especially our English learners,
have the opportunity to show their growth in multiple ways.
The pandemic has been an extremely challenging time
for our students and our teachers
and I am very excited to see and listen today
that there will be options for our kids
that honor their diversity, their voice,
and what we care about.
So thank you so much.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Emily Arias.
I am a 14-year-old student in Fontana
and I believe that LEAs do not need any more waivers
for testing at this point.
Police did not create any more waivers
to reduce accountability for these assessments.
By maintaining all the assessment as required,
we will learn the actual impact
that COVID had on all students.
Today, I asked the California State Board of Education
to protect special children.
Please vote no for any waivers.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Emily Arias.
I'm a parent in San Diego Unified
and also a co-founder of Reopen SDUSD.
I'm urging the board to vote no on any additional waivers.
I can tell you, we hear from parents every day.
They have no idea where their kids are at.
They are desperate for information
and our district did local assessments in the fall.
So what concerns me of localizing things
is that that is just not gonna make it out to parents
and they're not going to have anything comparable.
In terms of them being online and the challenges with that,
I find it astounding that districts bring that up
as a reason not to test.
For me, it's the exact reason why we should test
because it's the perfect reflection
of what kids are dealing with right now
and we need to know, we must have this data
if we're going to be able to move forward
and solve these problems correctly.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
This is Dr. Mary McNeil,
Superintendent of the Needles Unified School District
on the California-Arizona-Nevada border.
I'm requesting support for local options
for an assessment program this year.
For many years, we've used the NWEA map assessment
in ELA and math as benchmarks in kindergarten to upgrade.
We believe that this same assessment
would provide us with immediate information
we need to determine how to accelerate learning
following this year's instructional platform,
as well as provide realistic data
for both parents in district and our public.
We want to assess and receive valid data now
to determine where students are
and how we can move forward.
We have cohorts of in-person instruction.
We can work with parents to assess on-site and online
using our laptops and hotspots.
We can develop reports for district, parents,
and the public, and we have the ability
to report individual and student groups
to best understand how to reach each and every student.
Thank you for your consideration of supporting local options.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Yes, good afternoon, Dr. Darling Hammond,
Superintendent Thurman, and members of the state board.
My name is Nick Romley.
I'm calling on behalf of Dr. Mary Ann Dewan,
County Superintendent of Schools
in the Santa Clara County Office of Education.
Just quickly, Dr. Dewan would really like to thank
the board and CDE staff for all their hard work
and for their outreach to education stakeholders.
I would ask that the board approve CDE's recommendation
that for the 2020-21 school year, pardon me,
LEAs be able to use the most viable option
for the assessment in their local context.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Oh.
Hello.
Yes, caller, you're live.
I'm sorry, I didn't know that I had requested this.
I am a teacher and I'm also in public schools
for 17 years and I'm also an elected school board trustee.
And I am grateful to see CDC's recommendations
and I am calling in support of those local options
for our students.
Roughly 40% of our students are remaining virtual
and our third and fourth graders
have never seen the Smarter Balanced Assessment.
Giving them Smarter Balanced Assessment
would be a huge and unfair burden for our learners,
cause threats, and take away
from our precious instructional minutes.
Allowing the local assessments
that students and teachers are already familiar with
provides meaningful data and better options.
Thank you so much and sorry for my glitch at the beginning.
Thank you, caller.
This concludes public comment.
Thank you very much.
Board members, this is our opportunity for discussion
and we could take the public comment slide down now
so we can see each other, which will be helpful.
I'll be watching the raised hand function
in the participant queue and to kick us off,
I'm gonna start with Vice President Strauss.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So again, I wanted to thank Deputy Superintendent Maves
and Dr. Mao Leng for the presentation
and really setting the context.
Just thinking about districts going forward,
should we take action today?
This is really directed to Deputy Superintendent Maves.
I'm interested in what specific guidance
will be given to districts.
I know you're thinking about it.
I'm just interested in when they'll get the guidance,
what kind of guidance they'll get
regarding reporting requirements
based on this potential waiver requirement
and particularly how to address the separate subgroups.
So I know that's a lot,
but I know you've been thinking about it
and I appreciate any clarification.
So you had a few questions in there.
Thank you, Member Strauss
and I'll try to see if I can hit all of them.
The first one that I heard you ask was about communication.
So I think that we have found actually a pretty good rhythm
in these office hours
that we had started in the coffee sessions.
They are a weekly meeting
that we continue to provide updates
and I think that it's created a regular routine and rhythm
that we can utilize as we continue to discuss
and provide guidance to LEAs.
So I think as far as communication goes,
we have a pretty good platform.
We understand that there's going to need
to be a lot of support in the field
as this continues to move forward.
We will be sending out an email very shortly
after the board meeting to the field,
letting them know of what has decided at the board,
providing some supporting resources for that,
including registration links to our meeting next week
on Wednesday to discuss some of the updates
and any guidance that we have between now and then.
So we understand that
and we are putting some things in place
to make sure that we're increasing communication.
The second thing that I heard you ask
is about what specific guidance
we might be sharing with LEAs.
I think outside of,
and one of the things that I appreciate about Motion 5
that the board provided is that it already created
some pretty specific guard rails for us.
So I think there's pretty clear guidance
that whatever assessment they choose,
we've provided some considerations to be thinking about
with the 11th grade and the additional accommodations.
We've made it pretty clear
that the expectation for reporting
is going to be through the SARC
and that they should be able to aggregate
and disaggregate that data.
60% are using the iReady, MAP, and STAR,
and those are K-12 assessments that are available
and you can aggregate and disaggregate those
by student group.
So that piece, I feel like the motion
and what we're recommending today
provides some pretty clear guide rails.
There will be other things
that we are going to have to discuss.
Today was really about the policy discussion.
We will have a multitude of ongoing discussions internally
to continue to decide how we support
the implementation of this moving forward.
And I would be happy to bring back in May
or Dr. Mao Vang can bring back in May
an update with what we've done so far.
Thanks so much.
Member Rucker.
Thank you very much, Dr. Maves and Dr. Vang
for your very thorough presentation to the board
about the many facets that this waiver
would have an impact on.
I especially appreciate the time you took
to talk to us about the status
of the assessment activities going on
in the districts at this time.
The purpose of behind what the federal government
is intending in issuing the opportunity
to apply for this waiver
is to make sure that information is published
concerning the impact of the pandemic
on the academic gains and the instructional program
of our students.
I clearly heard a lot of those concerns
and those very clear distinctions
about how many stakeholders,
particularly our parents,
feel about the impacts of the pandemic
on what's happening with their child's school experience
over the past year or so.
So it doesn't take rocket science
to understand those things,
but at the same time,
there is a desire to have some uniform way
and some uniform set of data points
to further this discussion
and even validate some of the concerns or opinions.
So I really do appreciate not only what you did
in sharing with us where we are at this point
but the likely impacts and next steps
as we move forward in this discussion.
The one question I do have about this particular waiver
is not so much the timeline for the approval,
but with each successive week,
there are more and more districts
whose assessment window will open.
So how would the approval of this waiver
with the ideas and the options described
change the choices or the directions
that districts who have begun testing
would have in front of them?
Well, right now we're moving forward
with assessments as we have been.
And we've said that from the very beginning
that until we had,
I mean, one, we didn't have board approval
before today either.
So we have some other boxes that we need to check.
As soon as some of those boxes have been checked,
this is the first step in moving that forward
with your decision as the State Board of Education,
then it allows us to bring very quickly
the general waiver if necessary to ED,
as well as the required information for the legislature
to hopefully make the same decision
and provide relief from the state requirements.
So assuming all of those things happen moving forward,
then LEAs have the choices exactly outlined
within the recommendation that we're making.
They could choose to move forward
and continue to do the summative assessment
if they feel like that best meets their current context
and their student needs.
They could choose to use
another locally administered assessment
that they were required to have under SB 98
to already in place to assess
and monitor their students' progress.
So those choices would be up to the local LEA
to decide based on their current context and need.
Thank you for answering that question.
The reason why I asked the question in the way I did,
I heard very clearly from many stakeholders the concern
that something would be lost
by the board approving an action
that basically cancel statewide testing.
And that's not what this particular action
is intended to do.
It's intended to maximize the options
and the flexibilities that LEAs have
for their testing and assessment regimen
that's currently in place
and to give them the local option to choose
the best pathway for them to proceed
to continue with doing an assessment
and then developing a report from that assessment.
So that is the reason why I asked you that question.
I know that's probably seemed very pedantic
and I thank you for taking the time
to respond in the way that you did.
I'm just glad I got it right.
Member Berth.
Thank you.
So sort of to piggyback on what member Rucker said,
I just wanna reinforce what it says in our item
and clarify this that according to the stakeholder survey
that the department did,
approximately 77% of the LEA respondents
indicated they had used the following five local assessments
during the 2021 school year.
So I assume that means to date
they have been using these formative
or interim assessments.
Rachael's shaking her head yes.
So I think that's important.
And I do think that it confirms
what member Rucker was speaking to
that local LEAs have decided what works best for them.
My second question is,
and it's gonna sound like I'm kind of hung up on this
because I am, relates to the grade levels
because I understand that for purposes of a federal waiver,
we have to address the grade levels
that we're required to test in.
And we wanna be clear that if LEAs choose those,
they're reporting in those grade levels.
But I'm wondering because, and I'll just say
my most important desire
is that parents have the maximum amount
of information available.
If LEAs are in fact using these local assessments
across grade levels,
will there be an expectation in your communications to them
that they also report those results
to the extent they have them in grade levels
other than those that the feds require us to test in?
That's a great question, member Burr.
I think that when we look at the recommendation,
grades three through eight and 11, as you noted,
are the ones that are required
underneath our federal requirements
and our state requirements.
I do think that best practice is to communicate
that information at every grade level
that you have assessments available.
But we can continue to have those conversations
and then come back with an update
of what that guidance looks like at the May meeting.
Thank you.
I do not see other board members asking for recognition,
which may mean that we are ready for a motion.
Do I have a motion?
I would move CDE's recommendation.
Thank you, member Sun.
Do I have a second?
I second.
Thank you very much.
Is there any further discussion of the motion?
Seeing no hands raised,
Brooks will call a roll call vote, please.
Member Burr.
Aye.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Fata.
Aye.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Aye.
Member Patillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Vice President Strauss.
Aye.
Member Sun.
The motion carries unanimously.
Well, we have concluded more expeditiously
than we thought we might,
but we have two long days ahead of us.
So I wanna ask Brooks whether we could take
the closed session now to free us up a little bit more
in the next two days or whether we should adjourn.
I believe we should adjourn as the folks
are anticipating the other times to be available.
Yeah, well, we will continue to have
all those other times available,
but it's just us for closed session.
However, given that we have been so timely today,
you get some time back,
and I want you to hold on to this momentum
as we get ready to go through the next couple of days.
And member Rodriguez, did you want to make a comment?
I saw your hand go up.
No, that was accidental.
Okay, that was your dog, right?
Jumping on your, all right.
With that, I adjourn today's session.
I'll see you at 421 p.m.
and I will see you at 830 a.m. tomorrow morning.